laughs Donald ball fake back to Lou one  pon toppa got arrested on 2:24 Lou  Williams Clippers lead by 3k mother's  taken with six point four seconds to go  perfectly I think the latter three two  things I'm pretty sure we have a whole  bunch of desert over here because the  action was alive for mr. Lewin's going  left just look at the pity pack that  ball was throw back to die with us out  now settle three or two Oh Mark Davis  was in official indicators it was a tune  this foot was on the line  Ralph to two foot was on the line his  right foot was on the line  well annoyed get a three-point game and  set up a four point game but I'll tell  you what